what's up guys gone on a little skylines
video for you guys here and there are
some important things that I want to
talk about today because you may have
noticed that I haven't uploaded too many
videos of this game as of lately or hell
I haven't even uploaded too many videos
anyway which is due to a couple of
things and in general its the fact that
I'm going to have exams in two weeks and
I know that usually the excuse of saying
yeah I'm kind of busy with school is not
really the greatest excuse because if
you really want to do something you're
gonna find time for it anyway no matter
how busy you are but you know at this
point I have not that much spare time
and I do kind of want to do everything
that I want to do you know I've got Rada
cosec and three too but also real life
things and there is also a skyline
specific problem and that would be the
fact that I haven't opened it in a very
long time because I've had a really
terrible bug and it has to do with the
mods because if I turn the mods on the
game work works perfectly but no I mean
no if I turn them off the game works
perfectly but if I reinstall all my mods
then it just doesn't open it crashes on
the loading screen Oh 99 out of 100
times like ever you once in a while but
that is extremely rare it actually works
but it's really hard to get that and
lately I haven't gotten the game to work
with my mods on and if I turn the mods
of the city is not going to load because
it uses many mods and assets and things
that are quite crucial to the city
functioning so yeah that's the issue I
can turn the mods off if I want the game
to work but if I want to turn them on
and actually open the city it just
doesn't happen and that's one thing
that's keeping me from working on the
city so I kind of were to fix that but
there is also the fact that I'm actually
not too happy with the city as it is
right now I mean I like it but I feel
like it could be more realistic it's
it's generally well functioning but you
know the street layouts and things like
that
it isn't exactly realistically planned
so I want to start a new city and
actually get that to be more realistic
sometime
I don't know how soon that it's going to
be I'll probably still work on this city
though but it's something that's been
lurking in my mind as well but that's
just going to happen when I actually get
this game to work so that's quite a
couple of sad things right there I'm
moving on to the video
right now I guess actually because I
still do have some recordings of the
things out I have done before so you
don't have to worry too much about that
this is just a small neighborhood man I
wanted to get over here because you know
I bought this land anyway so might as
well build on it and actually expand the
city in this direction I wanted to get
some towns around the city as well
because you know it's not really
realistic to have just a city like this
in the middle of nowhere with nothing
around it but I just have any kind of a
lack of space but yeah you can see that
this neighborhood really develops in
this kind of curvy road pattern style
that the entire city has been in and
this is actually one of the reasons why
I am NOT that happy about the city
because even though it functions well
and I do like it I'm not really having
too many problems with anything and I
think it looks okay I feel like the road
pattern and the overall city planning is
just not realistic enough I mean it
works in this case but it's not really
something that I've seen and I think
that what I started out with which is
what in the beginning made me like my
city was ultimately the downfall of this
city because the road pattern is just
too urban style there's just you know
you've got one big city with all these
neighborhoods you're always gonna going
to have some neighborhoods that have
this suburban sound especially around
the outskirts of a city but since I
started out with that style you even I
eventually ended up with the center of
the city looking like a suburb and this
entire city basically looking like one
big [ __ ] of suburbs not to
mention the fact that the industrial
areas which are now being turned into
offer zones as you can see are built
more to be functional than to be
realistic and I think what I want more
than just a realistic city and what I
definitely want to experiment with is I
mean yeah I mean a well-functioning city
is something that I don't know I don't
even want per say it
it's I kind of want to go for any
realistic city and with all the traffic
problems that I may have with all the
garbage or whatever problem is to have
bodies all over the streets I don't care
as long as it's realistic is something
that I feel like I want to go for more
than a utopia of curvy roads and forests
everywhere but something that I don't
feel like could ever exist anywhere in
real life because the bigger the city
gets the more unnatural it feels as a
town it really felt natural on it was
developing in a very nice way but as it
got bigger and that was eventually its
downfall I think and then it's why I
want to start again and just ultimately
plan a city and do all kinds of things
to make it functional I guess but above
all actually realistic is something that
I can't wait to go for it which is also
probably going to work better with new
mods and stuff like that because that's
also one reason that I kind of want to
try this because there is a chance that
I never get this the city to work again
I don't know that if it's a bug that
will be fixed if there's going to be
some punch that can fix this but as of
now I can't open this city because of
the crushing bug when I have all the
mods on and I've used all these mods and
assets for this city and without them it
just doesn't work I've tried it and
everything everything was empty and it
was just weird alright so if I start a
new city I can clean my mod folder and
get new assets and remove my existing
ones that I don't like or aren't working
and glitching and stuff like that just
basically clean up everything and start
anew with more knowledge and more
everything basically which is very
tempting for me to try at the moment but
yeah in a couple in the next couple of
weeks I still won't be as busy and
uploading as frequently as I would like
to do it simply because exams and stuff
like that and I definitely still have
free time I mean even if I'm going to be
studying all day you know I'm still
gonna leave out a couple of hours just
to do something fun I'm not
not stupid but it there's no way I can
actually fix this too quickly and start
pumping out videos the way I was doing
it before but hopefully in the summer
vacation everything will be back to fun
times and I'll be able to do more videos
so I guess I should talk about the city
more often well that was a pretty
important update I guess this area in
the city it is actually one of my
favorite areas this is going to be one
of them more suburban kind of areas and
this one is pretty bland even though it
has those very straight road layouts
you'll see in a minute it has a cool
little round road pattern in the middle
which is the kind of thing that I like
it has to look somewhat natural but I
think I discovered while playing City
skylines that natural alone is not going
to work and a very structured alone is
also not going to work in you kind of
have to find that balance between a nice
looking road pattern that has the
aesthetic capabilities and a
well-functioning
wrote layouts that also looks like it's
realistic and something that could
happen in real life
I've also seen some people with wrote
layouts that are absolutely amazing like
all kinds of awesome patterns and things
like that but I don't think any city in
real life does that and I'm sorry if I
if I come across as someone who has a
obsession with it looking realistic but
you know I've always liked city building
and building a realist realistic city
for me it's just more fun than building
a utopia which is something that you can
easily do in any video game but it's
getting it to be realistic is a lot
harder than just getting the game to
work right and this mod is something
that I got from my Velichko second three
years which is still going on I don't
even know why I'm referring it to that
like that but it's something it's a
different type playing the game which i
think is something that works in wala co
second three is actually something
that's happening in city skylines as
well it's it's you can play it for the
the game itself or the gameplay and
getting all the achievements and getting
your city to be amazing and things like
that but you can also play it anymore
we trying to get a nice-looking city
without no not per se going for the
amazing achievements or perfect traffic
but rather a city that is aesthetically
pleasing and also realistic and I'm just
more a fan of the latter and I don't see
it too much people either just play the
game like they like to do it or they try
to fix all the issues that they have
within their city but eventually cities
like that always end up looking like a
city in a game rather than a city in
real life and as well functioning as
they may be and as perfect as they may
be I think a flaws in the city are what
can make a city perfect okay that one
that was way too deep for what I
actually meant but I guess I guess it
works but yeah I know that was my
message for the end of this video thank
you for watching and I'll see you on the
next episode in which I will be tackling
this street pattern in the downtown area
the downtown area is going to be
completely flattened demolished removed
and there's going to be a new one with a
new street pattern which is hopefully
going to be a little bit more realistic
and planned so I'll see you then